now I did see on your Instagram that you
told someone when you're doing ask me
anything is that you're maybe already
married
ed Sheeran shrugging off rumors he's
already married to cherry Seaborn I want
to take this interview as if you're not
already married will you sing at your
own wedding no will you have famous
friends sing at your wedding
will you have someone unknown that
you're very passionate about sing at
your wedding so they get discovered not
so they get discovered but yeah okay are
you a groomzilla no do you know what
that is
no always when you like when you're like
I need P knees in pink yeah I'm like I'm
not a big I don't like large groups of
people at the best time so like yeah I
don't I never wanted a wedding that was
loads of people I know got married in
the backyard yeah like it's a good boy
the singer also spoke about Seaborn's
role in his upcoming documentary
songwriter premiering August 28th on
Apple music your fiance slash wife did
appear in the documentary and I know
you're so private with your person yeah
I know that was that was a surprise to
watch it cuz I was like oh god is this
should this happen but it's fine more
than once though but why like that's a
big step because you are so private what
does that like I said no it was whizzed
it was weird for me weird for me but it
does contextualize some of it you know
it does and it normalizes it as well and
I think you know one of the main
criticisms someone said about this
documentary is it wasn't there was no
like how we got your moment or like it
but there was nothing personal in it
really it's just a thing about
songwriting but it is it doesn't say ed
Sheeran the life and times of it says ed
Sheeran somewhere I said so it's like
this is a documentary so like having
cherry in it yeah didn't seem like it
fit for me but it does in the grand
scheme of things
[Music]